[Music]
thank you for bringing us collectively
to this moment it is a moment but so
many have dreamed of claiming history
starts today
[Music]
the guy you were for is an evil person I
don't work for him my friend works for
Emily are you gonna behave yourself
tomorrow I told you more than my job I'm
a reporter I follow people that do not
want to be followed what about the
allegation is that you recruit the most
vulnerable for tests that end up killing
people you tell me a joke finish mr.
brahs was that a threat we had to learn
how to hide in plain sight I'm pretty
good at it for you
you suck whoever you are if I get a life
foundation and it needs your help we
found something we call them symbiosis
Carleton Drake believes that the union
between human and symbiote is the key to
our evolution
I'm feeling really sick
I'm here boys
you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back
why would we do that
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people will I see it do whatever we
want do we have a deal
willing to sacrifice
one thing you almost did
who should be extremely afraid
what the hell are you we
I'll fit
[Music]